T
TO BELARUS OFFICIALS.
WE HAVE A FRIEND OF PRATASEVICH
AND ANN APPLE BALM, JOURNALIST
AND AUTHOR, WRITTEN EXTENSIVELY
ABOUT EASTERN EUROPE.
WELCOME TO YOU BOTH.
LET ME BEGIN WITH YOU.
I WANT TO HEAR THE LATEST ON
YOUR FRIEND PRATASEVICH AND HIS
CONDITION.
WHAT HAVE YOU HEARD, I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU HEARD EARLIER
CONVERSATIONS, THERE ARE REPORTS
HIS MOTHER IS SAYING HE IS IN A
HOSPITAL IN MINSK.
WE HAVEN'T CONFIRMED THAT.
THAT WOULD BE AN HE ISESCALATIN
STEP.
WHAT HAVE YOU HEARD?
>> WE HEARD THE SAME
INFORMATION.
MOTHER AND FATHER OF RAMAN, THAT
HE IS WITH PROBLEMS WITH THE
HEART IN ONE OF THE MINSK
HOSPITALS.
BUT WE CAN'T PROVE THIS.
THIS INFORMATION CAME FROM
DOCTORS AND MEDICAL CIRCLES WHO
HEARD THAT HE WAS BROUGHT TO THE
HOSPITAL.
IT DOESN'T MEAN HE IS RELEASED.
HE IS STILL UNDER ARREST.
I KNEW HE HAD SOME PROBLEM WITH
HEART, I AM SURE DURING THE
DETENTION AND INTERROGATION HE
COULD BE PRESSED, PUSHED AND
POTENTIALLY TORTURED.
>> HE DID HAVE A HEART
CONDITION.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT MANY DID
NOT KNOW, WERE NOT AWARE OF,
QUESTIONED THE HEADLINE WHEN
THEY SEE HIS AGE, YOUNG MAN IN
HIS 20s.
BUT HE DOES HAVE A HEART
CONDITION?
>> I DON'T KNOW FOR SURE.
BUT YOU KNOW, I KNOW HE WAS
ALWAYS HAD CONCERNS ABOUT HIS
HEALTH.
ONE OF HIS ARGUMENTS NOT
RETURNING TO BELARUS AND BEING
DETAINED BY THE KGB, BECAUSE HE
HAS WEAK HEALTH.
HE WAS SAYING HE WILL NOT
SURVIVE IF KGB WILL CAPTURE HIM.
>> TELL US ABOUT RAMAN AND THE
LATEST WORK HE HAS BEEN DOING.
>> YOUNG GUY JOURNALIST TURNED
TO BE ACTIVIST, ROMANTIC.
HE WAS DRIVEN TO LIVE IN
BELARUS, FREE AND DEMOCRATIC
SINCE 17 WAS PARTICIPATING IN
THE MARCHES AND DURING THE LAST
TWO, THREE YEARS WAS MANAGING
SEVERAL COOL MEDIA PROJECTS.
HE WAS COLLECTING VIDEOS,
PICTURES, WORKING WITH CITIZEN
JOURNALISTS, AND MOST IMPORTANT,
HE WAS WRITING STRONG TEXT,
INSPIRING FOR NONVIOLENT
RESISTANCE.
HE BELIEVED THAT THEY MUST FIGHT
FOR FREEDOM AND DEMOCRACY AND HE
SUPPORTED THIS NONVIOLENT
REVOLUTION THAT STARTED LAST
AUGUST.
>> YOU WROTE A PIECE LAST YEAR
ON THE SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM
THAT HE WORKS FOR, THE NEXT
ALIVE.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THE
SITE AND THE WORK THEY'RE DOING?
>> THIS WAS A REALLY UNUSUAL AND
INTERESTING WAY OF CONDUCTING
OPPOSITION DEMONSTRATIONS LAST
SUMMER.
JUST FOR THOSE VIEWERS WHO DON'T
KNOW, THE DEMONSTRATIONS
HAPPENED IN THE WAKE OF A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION THAT WAS
STOLEN, THE CURRENT DICTATE OR
OF BELARUS RAN A VERY STRANGE
CAMPAIGN, CLEARLY CHEATED, AND
THE WINNER OR AT LEAST THE
PERSON WHO SHOULD HAVE BEEN
ACKNOWLEDGED AS WINNING THE MOST
VOTES WAS EVENTUALLY FORCED TO
FLEE THE COUNTRY.
THERE WERE A SERIES OF
DEMONSTRATIONS THAT WENT ON ALL
SUMMER.
ONE OF THE WAYS THEY WERE
ORGANIZED WAS THROUGH THE
TELEGRAM PANELS.
TELEGRAM IS AN APP THAT CAN BE
USED TO REACH PEOPLE, USED TO
POST INFORMATION, VIDEOS AND SO
ON.
RAMAN AND ANOTHER THAT WE'RE
SPEAKING TO AND OTHERS WERE
WORKING WITH THE CHANNELS IN
ORDER TO CONNECT PEOPLE IN
BELARUS.
AND THEY WERE IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THEY WEREN'T SHUTDOWN BY THE
GOVERNMENT, THE GOVERNMENT
COULDN'T SHUT THEM DOWN, THEY
WOULD HAVE TRIED TO.
THEY WERE ON PEOPLE'S PHONES AND
PEOPLE HAD ACCESS WHEN ALL OTHER
FORMS OF COMMUNICATION AND MEDIA
WERE SHUT OFF.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO STRESS HOW
CREATIVE AND HOW CUTTING EDGE
THE OPPOSITION WAS, INCLUDING
RAMAN, HOW THEY USED TOOLS OF
NEW TECHNOLOGY TO REACH PEOPLE,
BRING THEM TOGETHER.
THIS IS A COUNTRY THAT HADN'T
HAD A MAJOR MASS MOVEMENT BEFORE
LIKE THAT, AND NOW YOU CAN SAY
IT IS A MOVEMENT THAT TOUCHED
ALMOST EVERYBODY.
PEOPLE IN ALL WALKS OF LIFE, NOT
JUST THE URBAN CITIES, NOT JUST
INTELLECTUALS OR EDUCATED
PEOPLE, THE WORK OF THE YOUNG
PEOPLE BROUGHT TOGETHER THE
COUNTRY.
AND OF COURSE, THAT'S WHY THE
DICTATOR HATES RAMAN SO MUCH,
THAT'S WHY HE MADE THIS
EXTRAORDINARY STEP, BRINGING
DOWN A COMMERCIAL AIRLINER TO
ARREST HIM.
>> HOW BIG A CRISIS IS THIS FOR
THE EU WHEN YOU HAVE A POOR
COUNTRY ABLE TO DO SUCH A
DRASTIC THING WHERE YOU HAVE AN
EU MADE PLANE TRAVELING FROM ONE
EU NATION TO ANOTHER EU NATION
BROUGHT DOWN IN TERMS OF WHAT
THIS MEANS FOR THE EU, WHAT KIND
F CRISIS ARE THEY IN?
>> IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT MOMENT
FOR THE EU, PRECISELY BECAUSE
THIS IS IN FACT ONE OF A SERIES
OF THESE KINDS OF EVENTS THAT
HAPPENED THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
WE'VE SEEN RUSSIAN SECRET
SERVICE MURDER RUSSIAN
DISSIDENTS, OPPOSITION FIGURES
ACROSS EUROPE.
MOST NOTABLY IN LONDON IN
SALISBURY.
WE HAVE SEEN IRANIAN AND CHINESE
ATTEMPT TO ASSASSINATE THEIR
CITIZENS ABROAD.
THIS IS ANOTHER FORM OF WHAT
SOME CALL TRANSNATIONAL
OPPRESSION, REACHING OUT ACROSS
BORDERS TO ARREST ORCHID NAT --
OR KIDNAP.
INCREASINGLY, OTHER EU CITIZENS
AND PEOPLE ARE EFFECTED BY THESE
ATTACKS AND THEY CREATE A
GENERAL SENSE OF LAWLESSNESS.
IF THE EU AND BY THE WAY,
APPLIES TO THE UNITED STATES AND
OTHER DEMOCRACIES, IF WE ARE NOT
ABLE TO CONTROL WHAT GOES ON
INSIDE OUR BORDERS TO PREVENT
PEOPLE KIDNAPPED AND MURDERED,
SOMETIMES THEY'RE OUR CITIZENS
AS WELL, SLOWLY THEY GAIN
CONFIDENCE AND THE BELIEF THEY
CAN DO IT MORE AND MORE.
FOR THE EU, IT IS AN IMPORTANT
MOMENT TO DRAW A LINE TO SAY
THIS CANNOT CONTINUE BECAUSE
OTHER COUNTRIES ARE GOING TO BE
WATCHING WHAT HAPPENS HERE.
AS I SAID, RUSSIANS, CHINESE,
RA
IRANIANS ARE SEEING HOW THE EU
REACTION.
THIS IS A TOOL OTHERS COULD USE
AS WELL.
>> GLOBAL AIRLINERS FLY OVER
THEIR AIR SPACE ON A DAILY
BASIS.
YOU WERE ON A FLIGHT LAST WEEK
WITH EXILED OPPOSITION LEADER ON
THE SAME FLIGHT.
YOU HAPPENED TO GET DIVERTED
LAST MINUTE, SHE WAS ON AIR
YESTERDAY SAYING IT COULD HAVE
HAPPENED TO HER HAD YOU NOT BEEN
DIVERTED.
THIS IS CHANGING HOW YOU
CONSIDER PLANNING AND TRAVELING
AS WELL, IS IT NOT?
>> THE SPECIAL OPERATION TO
BE -- ONE WEEK AGO, WAS
RETURNING FROM ATHENS, TAKING
THE SAME FLIGHT.
I WAS WITH HER.
THAT MOMENT, WE WERE FLYING OVER
B
BELARUS.
POTENTIALLY WE COULD BE IN
PRISON RIGHT NOW.
UNFORTUNATELY, RIGHT NOW AFTER
YESTERDAY'S INCIDENT, NO ONE CAN
FEEL SAFE ANY MORE.
AFTER YESTERDAY'S INCIDENT,
BELARUS CRISIS BECOMES NOT ONLY
DOMESTIC ISSUE BUT BECOMES A
THREAT TO THE ENTIRE EUROPE.
THIS IS WHY EUROPEAN UNION,
WESTERN STATES MUST CONSIDER
BROAD PACKAGE OF SANCTIONS.
THIS REACTION MUST NOT ONLY BE
WORDS BUT HOW TO ISOLATE THE
REGIME ON ONE HAND AND SUPPORT
CIVIL SOCIETY.
GROUPS SUCH AS MEDIA, DOCTORS,
TEACHERS, STUDENTS, WORKERS,
CONTINUE THEIR FIGHT BUT NEED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE, NEED
SUPPORT NOW.
>> AND THIS ISN'T JUST A ONE OFF
INCIDENT, WE CAN GO BACK MANY
YEARS AND LOOK AT WHAT
AUTHORITARIAN REGIMES AND WHAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN AND HIS
AGGRESSIONS THROUGHOUT THE
REGION AND POISONING HIS
OPPONENTS ON EUROPEAN SOIL AND
ON EUROPEAN LAND, YES, SANCTIONS
WERE IMPOSED, CLEARLY NOT ENOUGH
TO DETER HIM, PREVENT HIM FROM
FURTHER ACTIONS.
WHAT SHOULD BE DONE SINCE THIS
HAS TRANSPIRED FOR YEARS.
SHOULD THERE BE TOUGHER
SANCTIONS, BY THAT, GOING AFTER
THAT PIPELINE, TOO.
>> I WOULD THINK BEFORE EUROPE
TOUCHES THE PIPELINE ISSUE,
THERE WILL HAVE TO BE A PROVEN
LINK BETWEEN THIS EVENT AND
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT, AND IT IS
VERY POSSIBLE WE WILL GET THAT.
I DOUBT VERY MUCH LUKASHENKO
WOULD DARE TO DO THIS WITHOUT
RUSSIAN BACKING.
THERE'S BEEN NOISES OF APPROVAL
FROM MOSCOW FOR THE INCIDENT.
I THINK BEFORE WE GET THERE,
THINGS TO WATCH FOR, ONE THE
AIRLINE THAT WE MAY HEAR MORE
ABOUT THAT THE NEXT COUPLE OF
DAYS.
THE OTHER IS CUTTING OFF ALL
FLIGHTS TO BELARUS.
ANOTHER POSSIBILITY.
THE EU IS BEGINNING TO LOOK AT
MORE SERIOUS SANCTIONS DIRECTED
AT BELLARUS THAN BEFORE.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
IF NONE OF THEM SUFFICE OR WORK,
MUCH BIGGER, MORE SIGNIFICANT
ECONOMIC ACTIONS WILL HAVE TO BE
TAKEN.
IT IS IN THE EUROPEAN STATES'
OWN INTEREST NOT TO BE MURDER,
NOT TO BE PLANES BROUGHT DOWN,
FOR THERE NOT TO BE THESE
INCIDENTS WITHIN THEIR BORDERS.
WE MAY WELL SEE A GREATER
INTEREST CERTAINLY IN BIGGER,
LARGER KINDS OF SANCTIONS,
INCLUDING THE NORDSTREAM
PIPELINE.
>> NO EVIDENCE RIGHT NOW THAT
RUSSIA SIGNED OFF, KNEW OF IT,
WAS AWARE OF IT.
BUT IT WAS A RUSSIAN MIG THAT
FORCED IT TO LAND.
HOURS AFTER THIS HAPPENED, SHE
SAID SHE NEVER THOUGHT SHE WOULD
BE AS JEALOUS OF LUKASHENKO, CON
GRAT LATED HIM ON HIS WORK.
WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN KNEW OF
AHEAD OF TIME, IT ISN'T
SOMETHING HE IS CONDEMNING.
>> NO, HE IS NOT, AND IT IS
CLEAR.
LUKASHENKO NOW HAS NO FRIENDS IN
EUROPE.
HE'S DEEPER AND DEEPER ECONOMIC
CRISIS, ECONOMY IS FALTERING.
HE MAY NEED MILITARY AND OTHER
KINDS OF SUPPORT.
IT IS CLEAR NOW THAT ONE COUNTRY
HE IS RELYING ON IS RUSSIA.
AND IT IS RUSSIA WHO WILL -- BY
THE WAY, ANOTHER ELEMENT OF THE
NEW FORM OF AUTHORITARIANISM,
COUNTRIES SUPPORT AND PROP EACH
OTHER UP.
RUSSIA BACKS VENEZUELA, IRAN
BACKS CHINA.
THESE ARE NOW, THERE'S A NETWORK
OF COUNTRIES THAT SEEK TO
SUPPORT ONE ANOTHER, AND FOR
BELARUS, MOST IMPORTANT ONE IS
RUSSIA.
>> AND FOR VIEWERS AROUND THE
WORLD, BOTH IN THE U.S. AND
EUROPE AND ASIA, WHEN YOU SEE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS TAKE PLACE,
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO THEM?
THEY MAY SAY I AM NOT AN
OPPOSITION LEADER, I SHOULDN'T
WORRY.
WHY SHOULD THIS BE SOMETHING
THAT IMPACTS ALL OF US?
>> BECAUSE BELARUS WAS FIGHT
FFOR
FREE AND FAIR ELECTIONS AND
HUMAN RIGHTS.
RIGHT NOW, THEY'RE EXPECTING THE
PERSON WORLD WILL BE SUPPORTING
THEM.
JUST 30 MINUTES AGO, THEY
CONDUCTED A CALL WITH THE
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER JAKE
SULLIVAN, DISCUSSED HOW THE U.S.
CAN SUPPORT.
I FEEL CONFIDENT, WE SEE AND
HEAR WORDS OF SUPPORT BUT
SOMETIMES WORDS ARE NOT ENOUGH.
WE NEED ACTIONS.